ja vielen dank bei uns geht es hier im
deutschen bundestag natürlich auch
wieder im weitesten sinne um das thema
corona nämlich um das impfen das ist das
a und o bei der bekämpfung dieser
pandemie das ist völlig klar
bislang gab es zu wenig impfdosen in
deutschland man rechnet damit dass in
drei vier wochen es eher zu viel geben
wird und deswegen hat die runde im
kanzleramt am mittwoch ja auch
beschlossen dass nun die hausärzte
involviert werden sollen ende des monats
endlich sagen viele
und es wird aber auch immer deutlicher
in der pandemie dass die deutsche
verwaltung überfordert scheint und die
digitalisierung nicht ausreichend ist
vor allem wenn man im vergleich zum
ausland
mal schaut darüber wollen wir uns gleich
unterhalten und naja dann ist es so dass
der erste punkt hier im deutschen
bundestag der weltfrauentag ist da wird
diskutiert am montag ist er in berlin
ist er sogar feiertag und diese debatte
werden ihnen ausnahmsweise heute nicht
live zeigen nur bei uns im internet über
youtube weil wir dann gleich in die
bundespressekonferenz um 9 uhr schalten
dort wird der lkw chef wieder der
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen und der
nordrhein westfälische
gesundheitsminister laumann stellung
nehmen auch dort das thema impfen und
schnell jazz genau wie bei uns und ich
will mich jetzt hier über die initiative
der fdp unterhalten die um ungefähr 10
uhr 15 hier im deutschen bundestag
beraten wird der antrag um einen im
portal ganz spannend und ich will
darüber reden mit erwin rüddel dem
vorsitzenden des gesundheitsausschusses
des deutschen bundestages von der cdu
und android mann der gesundheitsexperte
der fdp herr riedel bevor ich anfange
ganz aktuell astrazeneca ist seit
gestern offensichtlich auch jetzt in
deutschland erklärt worden dass man das
für ältere menschen ab 65 impfen kann
das ist aber glaube ich gerade ein ganz
gutes beispiel astrazeneca warum wir so
hinterher hängen
erstens haben wir recht spät bestellt
und zum zweiten hat die ema dann
sorgfältig geprüft in europa und hat
gesagt dieser impfstoff ist in ordnung
der kann verimpft werden und die
deutschen behörden haben dann gesagt ja
aber es waren zu wenige
der erhebungsmethode machen wir mal
lieber unter 65 typisch deutsch in einer
pandemie das können uns eigentlich
eigentlich leisten und den erfolg sehen
wir jetzt ja wir haben immer mehr zulauf
an impfstoff es ist schön dass jetzt
astra zenica auch für ältere werden kann
wir müssen jetzt sehen dass wir auch
impfstoffe bekommen
für die jüngeren und ja wir sind
vorsichtig unterwegs
in großbritannien hat man mit
zulassungen oder gearbeitet in israel
hat man praktisch die bereitschaft
gehabt daten zur verfügung zu stellen
über deren auswertungen wir jetzt auch
unseren nutzen ziehen
aber sie haben recht wir sind den weg
gegangen der vorsicht und glaube aber
auch dass es richtig ist weil man sich
auf den impfstoff verlassen können muss
weil wir ja unsere bevölkerung in großem
rahmen impfen wollen und das auch jetzt
nach anfänglichen kleineren schritten
weil der zulauf am anfang natürlich
gering war aber jetzt mit jedem tag jede
woche größer wird und wir müssen jetzt
sehen dass wir große dynamik in den im
prozess bekommen und bin da sehr
zuversichtlich sobald die ärzte
einsteigen können werden wir hier große
fortschritte machen und sie sind auch
infektologe von hause aus und deswegen
noch mal die frage die stiko hat ja
nichts falsch gemacht die hat das
geprüft die dass sich ordentlich in
deutschland gehört die immer war auch
viel langsamer als zum beispiel
großbritannien israel oder amerika weil
man auch das geprüft hat und keinen
notfall zu lassen wollte können wir uns
das eigentlich leisten war das nicht
typisch deutsch und ist das nicht einer
der gründe warum wir jetzt so hinterher
hin
nein das ist sicherlich nicht einen
grund form hinterher hinken wir
hinterher weil die europäische union
nicht rechtzeitig genug chargen bestellt
hat das war ein managementfehler von pro
von der leyen im vorfeld sie hätte
eigentlich viel mehr bestellen können da
hätte sich gelohnt dazu investieren auf
risiko zu investieren statt eine höhere
verschuldung in der eu ob wir auch in
deutschland
ich finde dass die ema einen guten job
gemacht hat die haben innerhalb von vier
wochen eine
eine bedingte zulassung ausgesprochen
aufgrund der datenlage das ist ja
wichtig dass die sicherheit und die
effektivität eines impfstoffes
gewährleistet ist ist es tatsächlich so
die daten haben fehlen über 55 jahre
um ausreichend eine aussage treffen ob
dieser impfstoff effektives oder nicht
viele glauben daran dass es
funktionieren wird ich glaube auch daran
aber die daten fehlen deswegen war die
empfehlung der stiko erst unter 65
zuzulassen die richtige empfehlung jetzt
in neue daten entstanden in england und
schottland mit beobachtungsstudien die
haben gezeigt dass diese impfstoffe
tatsächlich überall alter von 65 jahren
effektiv ist und deswegen ist diese
revidierte entscheidung genau die
richtige aber die verzögerung war
letztlich die bestellung im sommer der
bürger ist natürlich kein infektologe
deswegen sagt er die politiker sagen
schon irgendwas stimmt mit diesem
impfstoff nicht also will ich den auch
nicht und genau so ist es passiert
astrazeneca nicht in übermäßigen maße
aber ist doch liegen geblieben das
können wir uns ja überhaupt nicht
leisten und der zweite punkt ist in
israel zum beispiel wird jetzt immer
nach vorne gehoben weil die auch schon
ungefähr 45 bis 48 prozent der
bevölkerung durch geimpft haben in
israel wie zb bei ikea gf dass da sind
wir nicht nur malen weit von entfernt
sondern unsere bürokratie verhindert ja
bisher auch so dinge dass wir eventuell
hausärzte oder betriebs rcds schon seit
monaten anbieten mit involvieren da ist
die politik jetzt einen schritt
weitergegangen in drei wochen soll es
soweit sein
wir sind zu langsam also und wir sind
vorsichtig und bin die hausärzte
einsteigen dann brauchen wir viel
impfstoff und diesen zulauf den haben
wir in den nächsten wochen monaten so
dass also die hausärzte oder die
impfärzte insgesamt auch die fachärzte
einsteigen können in den im prozess wir
hatten es gab in der bevölkerung
zurückhaltung was den impfstoff astra
zenica angeht ich denke im dezember gab
es vorbehalte gegen den impfstoff von
bayern tag ihr ist aufklärungsarbeit
geleistet worden bei astrazeneca ist
auch entsprechend aufklärungsarbeit
geleistet worden
die bürger wissen jetzt wenn in
deutschland ein impfstoff zugelassen
wird dann hilft der zu 100 prozent gegen
schwere verläufe
es gibt ein restrisiko bei dem ein oder
anderen impfstoff für leichte verläufe
aber insgesamt weiß der bürger dass die
impfstoffe bei uns sicher sind und die
akzeptanz von astrazeneca ist ja
entsprechend auch deutlich gestiegen und
wir werden noch im märz den johnson
johnson impfstoff bekommen der nur noch
einmal verdient werden muss das wird
eine neue dynamik bei den ärzten geben
und wir haben ja im grunde zwei
strategien was die ärzte angeht jetzt im
märz bekommen die ärzte noch den
impfstoff die die entsprechende
zulassung erhalten von den ländern und
müssen sich an die priorisierung
vorgaben halten und anfang april öffnet
sich dann praktisch das portal für alle
ärzte die impfen wollen und da gehe ich
davon aus dass dann die priorisierung
weitestgehend in den hintergrund rückt
die priorisierung wird dann weiterhin
effizient laufen über die impfzentren
und die niedergelassenen ärzte werden
dann mehr freiheiten haben und wir
setzen da auf das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der ärzte
klingt alles unglaublich kompliziert die
ärzte sollen jetzt also in
eigenverantwortung dann selber
entscheiden wie die priorisierung ist
nach maßgabe der stiko und des
bundesgesundheitsministers das wird ein
einziges kuddelmuddel geben sie
empfehlen einen impf portal denn da gibt
es auch ein kuddelmuddel man ruft
irgendwo an in einem land und kommt
nicht durch bisher funktioniert das
überhaupt nicht gut was ist denn der
vorteil an einem im portal und warum
soll das besser funktionieren schauen
sie mal was bei den impfzentren zurzeit
passiert ist sehr unterschiedlich in
einer stadt lockt das perfekt einer
anderen stadt stehen fast 100 menschen
im regen
es regnet oder anderen staates heißt es
ja tut mir leid gehen sie wieder nach
hause
40 50 menschen stehen vor allem ins
zentrum bei minustemperaturen und dann
stellt man fest hoppla gehabt noch keine
termine diesen chaos beseitigen auch der
anderen stadt gibt es eine halde von
vielen impfstoff und auf der anderen
haben die keine impfstoffe aber da man
nicht in dieser 1 stadt wohnt kann man
sich doch nicht impfen lassen
wir sitzen eigentlich auf
digitalisierung in diesem bereich wo wir
ein software programm haben
wo die menschen sicher einen termin
bekommen oder ein reserveteam sogar
bekommen können weil gibt ja auch so
genannte no shows bei den impfzentren
dass man sehr schön einspringen kann
sodass wir effektiv die impfstoffe auch
verwenden können und das können nämlich
auch dann die hausärzte und die
fachärzte und die betriebsärzte sich
ebenfalls einloggen wenn sie wollen um
dann auch patienten dann zu sehen wäre
dann kommen dem tag kommt und die
filmstoffe sie brauchen ja das mit dem
einloggen dazu gehe ich so ein bisschen
denn die ärzte die demnächst mit impfen
sollen die müssen wir dann auch korrekt
zurückmelden wäre dann wie geimpft
worden ist sie müssen im übrigen auch
kühl vorrichtungen vor halten weil
bayern tag zum beispiel nur bei minus 70
grad hält das sind ja alles hürden
wir sind ein jahr nach der pandemie da
eigentlich noch überhaupt nicht gerüstet
oder also ich kann den vorschlag
nachvollziehen im portal zum beispiel
weil in vielen ländern die terminvergabe
einfach nicht funktioniert die
impfzentren funktionieren hervorragend
die terminvergabe würde ich mal sagen es
also auf jeden fall zu verbessern
nur bis wir ein internationales im
portal haben sind wir mit ihm fertig
deshalb glaube ich brauchen wir nicht
mehr bürokratie sondern wir brauchen
mehr flexibilität bei den ärzten und was
also die lagerhaltung angeht was die
logistik angeht
die ärzte sind gewohnt zu impfen die
impfen nicht nur gegen masern oder
walken oder gürtelrose sondern jedes
jahr und im letzten jahr etwa 30
millionen menschen gegen grippe
die logistik steht über den apotheken
großhandel der ärzte bekommen dann ihren
impfstoff über die apotheke in die
arztpraxis und was die lagerhaltung
angeht ist das basta zenica und johnson
& johnson überhaupt kein problem
das sind es ähnlich wie bei grippe
impfstoff und bei bayern tag gibt es
mittlerweile auch vorgaben
dass man also über mehrere tage bei
kühlschranktemperatur den impfstoff
lagern kann außerdem habe ich eben
gesagt wird es weiterhin die impfzentren
geben die auch praktisch als plan b die
priorisierung weiter umsetzen sodass
also auch denkbar ist dass in den
arztpraxen
astra zenica und johnson & johnson wird
um den impfzentren und wenn man das
klingt wieder alles so einfach meint
politologe hat mir gesagt ich habe auch
nicht die zeit und in der tat als ich
unlängst beim war das wartezimmer ist
voll mit 80 jährigen und älteren die
haben ganz schwere erkrankungen um die
diese art sich kümmern muss und es ist
bei weitem nicht so für einen arzt eine
grippeschutzimpfung man muss vorher ein
sehr langes vor gespräch führen
man muss dokumentieren man muss 30
minuten sitzen viele arztpraxen haben
diese möglichkeiten gar nicht also ganz
so einfach wie die politik uns das hier
weiß machen wird ist es doch vor ort gar
nicht also der arzt muss grundsätzlich
aufklären und ein einverständnis
einholen für eine impfung das ist nichts
neues das ist auch nichts besonderes ob
jetzt gewinnt 19 oder eine
grippeschutzimpfung dauert eine minute
wollen sie haben ist wieder da der
gruppe aber das ist keine richtige
aufklärung also muss man es schon
aufklären wir mal ein impfstoff oder
gelbfieber impfung fsme-impfung es gibt
viele verschiedene infektionskrankheiten
gegen den man sich impfen lassen kann
und da bedarf es einer aufklärung und
das ist das normale ärztliche handeln
der berufsverband deutscher internisten
beispielsweise eine umfrage unter den
niedergelassenen internisten gestartet
und da sind 80 prozent der
niedergelassenen internisten die auch
aus ärztlicher ethik sind bereit diese
impfstoffe auch zu verabreichen
natürlich auch lege artis das heißt man
entsprechende aufklärung so dass mehr
bei mir zu bis auf der internistischen
seither keine sorge existieren herum
einer ruhigen stunde lang weiteren sie
tun das um 10 uhr 15 meine damen und
herren dann sehen wir uns wieder hier im
deutschen bundestag